mental vlog depuis la maison attention
demain ça reprend dans notre bulle on
salue comme le laissait entendre le
titre put taklit d'aujourd'hui je vais
vous apprendre à retenir les pays sur
une carte de géographie
c'est donc une vidéo plus orienté
mémoire aujourd'hui j'essaie vraiment de
tout alternée en ce moment je reprends
un petit peu ça quand même et le but de
cette vidéo est double c'est déjà de
pouvoir retenir des pays de tête c'est à
dire que si on vous donne une carte
vierge vous êtes capable de réécrire les
pays mais aussi de mémoire de pouvoir
dire quels pays est frontalier avec quel
pays de pouvoir mieux situer sa
cartographie donc sa géographie
alors quelles méthodes aujourd'hui
s'offre à nous quand on veut essayer
d'apprendre ça et bien aucune la seule
méthode c'est d'apprendre d'imaginer à
peu près dans sa tête d'essayer de
retenir mais il n'y a pas de vraie
méthode que nous apprendrait les
professeurs pour apprendre ça j'ai pas
une recette toute faite qui va permettre
de faire le gros miracle du siècle mais
au moins une méthodologie pour le faire
on va prendre comme exemple une carte on
connaît bien et au moins même si vous
n'êtes pas l'école et que ça vous sert
pas à l'école ce but serbe dans votre
culture générale
on va prendre l'europe la carte de leur
carte de l'europe ici en temps normal
sauf si je la mets pas au montage et là
ce serait ridicule
alors je la mettrais si vous regardez
l'italie ça fait une botte c'est quelque
chose qu'on sait depuis toujours la
botte qui représente quitter c'est la
première pierre de notre édifice tout va
partir là dessus ne prenez pas peur
c'est simple à faire le secret c'est de
trouver de trois images qui nous
viennent par pays alors ça peut être
avec la forme des frontières la forme du
pays mais avec qu'autre chose
on va y revenir regardez l'autriche par
exemple l'autriche moi ça me rappelle un
petit peu une autruche une autruche qui
serait plus ou moins allongé en tout cas
on ne verrait pas les pattes avec son
long cou qui part en direction de la
suisse et autriche et autruches ça se
ressemble donc autruches autriche nous
noté rien pour l'instant je vais vous
expliquer ensuite comment on va faire un
besoin d'être un prof c'est terrible la
croatie pour moi ça me fait penser un
petit peu une tête de dinosaures avec la
gueule ouverte dont l'oeil serait à gré
ou aussi une pince à linge mais comme
j'ai commencé à vous l'expliquer les
images générées peuvent être indirecte
noter tout ce que ce pays vous évoque la
république tchèque ça m'évoque rien par
ses frontières par contre république
tchèque ça me fait penser un chèque un
chèque bancaire ça me fait aussi penser
à un check check mon pote pour la suisse
souvent dit en plaisantant que la suisse
est le pays des médicaments et bien la
suisse si je pense un peu aux
médicaments tout ça ça me fait penser à
un virus je trouve qu'elle a la forme
grosse bactéries sur pattes d'un virus
un peu bizarre tout est valable à partir
du moment où ça vraiment un sens un peu
précis pour vous par exemple la pologne
la pologne quand je regardais ça me dit
ça n'a rien de particulier mais pologne
ça me fait penser à paulo mais paulo ça
me fait penser à la chanson paulo de
stromae stromae pour les plus riches
donc la pologne me fait penser à lui
maintenant ce que vous pouvez faire sur
une carte de l'europe ou sur une carte
que vous essayer d'apprendre c'est
d'imprimer la carte vierge sans pays à
l'intérieur juste le nom du pays de
notaire la limite et vous notez pour
chaque pays ce que ça vous évoque comme
image directement dans le pays ce que ça
vous évoque de manière naturelle pour
vous pour certains c'est sûr faudra se
creuser un petit peu la tête mais à une
époque où je donnais des formations sur
la mémoire il n'y a jamais personne qui
a complètement séché même si vous croyez
ne pas pouvoir trouver quelque chose en
vrai vous pouvez faites vous confiance
même les chemins les plus tortueux sont
possibles et sont logiques regarder ce
que j'ai fait avec la pologne
vient ensuite la phase où vous allez
commencer associer les pays entre eux
par rapport aux possibilités encore une
fois hélas si on regarde l'europe
j'ai spontanément une histoire met
vraiment en plus elle me revient j'ai
même pas eu besoin de regarder des notes
quoi que ce soit le truche est en train
de manger un gros virus pour moi elle
est allongée elle mange un gros virus et
elle est elle même assise dans un ennui
donc l'autruche c'est l'autriche le
virus et la suisse donc je sais que au
bout
l'autriche gala suisse et je sais que
l'autriche est placée au dessus d'un nid
et le nid je sais que c'est la slovénie
mais en vrai dans mon imaginaire ce
qu'elle prend pour un ligne est en fait
l'espèce de touffes de cheveux blonde
d'un énorme crotales la gueule ouverte
crotales pour croatie et en guise de
plumage vous savez au niveau des fesses
de l'autruche ya toujours des grandes
plumes vertes en guise de plumage du pot
vers le bas il ya un gros chèque
ce chèque qu'il n'est pas pour n'importe
qui il est pour paulo qui est juste
au-dessus paulo pour la pologne échec
pour le public tchèque paulo qui va se
servir du chèque pour aller danser un
slow avec une femme gries cas des ongles
très long et la femme grise avec les
ongles longs pour moi femme grise ongles
c'est hongrie je pense que vous
comprenez la mécanique
il faut que vous trouviez la vôtre avec
comme ça des paquets de pays suivants la
carte que vous avez à prendre et vous
relier ça ensemble essayer de créer des
scènes des images comme ça qu'ils
s'associent exactement comme vient de
vous faire dans la démonstration et
voyez ce que vous pouvez relier ensemble
il se peut qu'à la fin il ya quelques
pays sur la carte que vous devez
apprendre que vous n'avez pas pu relier
d espèce de no man's land comme ça qui
reste un petit peu seul vous pouvez soit
essayer d apprendre par coeur
d'une manière plus classique ou de
prendre le temps encore une fois de
trouver une image correspondant tout un
petit quelque chose qui fait que vous
savez que les 3 que vous n'arrivez pas à
placer après au final dans l'ordre cepiv
pas fait paf c'est une méthode qui
fonctionne très bien
encore une fois je sais que certains
d'entre vous vont se dire non mais ça
c'est encore plus compliqué que de le
faire autant le faire normalement vous
avez droit de penser ça il n'y a pas de
problème maintenant moi ce que je vous
dis c'est que ça ça marche
moi ça a toujours marché pour moi ça a
marché pour ceux à qui je l' ai appris
qu on essayait de le refaire donc si
vous galérez à prendre vos cartes en
géographie prenez le temps d'essayer de
faire ça c'est plus long à
l'apprentissage du moins ça semble plus
long mais en vrai c'est pas plus long au
final et ça tient beaucoup mieux que
vous avez pas besoin de réviser moi dans
mes images c'est très clair quand quand
je quand je pense à l'autruche je vois
tout de suite les frontière de
l'autriche je vois ce que ça donne c'est
pas quelque chose qui peut s'apprendre
comme ça la forme des frontières
autrement et quand je pensais le trou et
je vois tout de suite la suisse voit le
nid je vois le crotale je vois le chèque
je vois pour l'autre ça se compose
instantanément j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu mais encore plus j'espère
qu'elle vous servir à si c'est le cas
c'est super et n'oubliez pas il faut que
je me déplace pour sa de vous abonner à
la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait le
portel blog c'est toujours une vidéo par
jour pendant un an du 1er au 31 décembre
et demain j'ai une invitée sur la chaîne
alors rendez vous demain à 17h csars
vous
[Musique]